las vegas woman is asking for the
community's help in identifying a
hit-and-run driver tonight well the
incident took place wednesday afternoon
in the northeast valley mary jane
belliesa shares how that woman is hoping
dash cam video will help catch the
culprit
pamela says she was driving west on
stuart near bruce to pick up her
daughter from school when she was hit by
a man driving a green truck she said it
was only moments before the driver took
off from the scene fortunately the whole
hit and run was caught on video thanks
to another driver's dash cam i realized
i was in danger
almost instantaneously actually happy i
was okay and could
think and i could move
because i was scared in this dash cam
video you can see a green dodge dakota
truck heading east on stuart from bruce
i heard the sound of the car of someone
peeling out very fast
and then i noticed a car truck around
the corner
and it was kind of out of control there
was a fishtail
and i was concerned for the driver was
going to go go on his side and then
he corrected and then he was coming
straight for me and then
next thing i know he was
hit
carlos morales a personal injury
attorney says as a safety precaution you
should never chase after the driver but
try to get the license plate if you can
or if you can
remember the details of the car right
like what what model what color
if you can see the driver what they look
like
and immediately take those mental notes
pamela did post this video to several
facebook groups in hopes someone will
recognize the driver she is also in
contact with police to file a report she
says she is thankful for everyone who
stopped and helped her reporting near
bruce and stewart mary jane villasa live
local now